the final step in a long court process
that's been followed closely across the
world George Pell the most prominent
Catholic figure to be convicted of child
abuse wasn't in court to hear his final
bid for freedom but some of his
supporters and opponents were emotions
were running high and opinions divided
and here this you know to be the voice
of the the our survivors that have
suffered at the hands of the likes of
George Pell in the Catholic Church I
hope will be celebrate the acquittal
defect arc we deliver a manifest for the
innocent man in late 2018 Pell was found
guilty of sexually abusing two choir
boys in the 1990s he served one year of
a six-year prison term and has continued
to maintain his innocence House lawyers
lost an appeal last year to overturn his
conviction over the next two days
they're arguing to the High Court that
that ruling was unreasonable his team
has focused its argument on the
credibility of a witness and the timing
of the offending lawyer Lisa Flynn who
represents abuse victims is concerned
that if the high court overturns his
conviction it might stop other abuse
victims speaking out this case has been
followed by many survivors and victims
all around the world in terms of it
really showing that people could come
forward and that they would be believed
and that police will lay charges and
that juries will believe them despite
being a convicted sex offender George
Pell is still a cardinal but so far the
Pope has declined to comment until all
avenues of Appeal are exhausted that
moment may not be far away now Nicola
gage al Jazeera Canberra